today we're going to take a look at
coins
equine is a piece of code that prints
its own source code and you might think
that should be pretty simple for example
in javascript you just write a console
log you type out the source code of the
program and you're done but with that
method there's no way of getting the
outermost console log lines don't really
have a real world utility but they are a
beautiful expression of programming joy
so i would like to create one today
[Music]
so first let's try something really
stupid
so we try to to add another console log
in inside
and as we can see we have two console
logs in the source code but we can only
print inside of that so there's no way
to get to the outer one
so we need to do something
smart here
so
if we create a function
call it f
and inside that
let's do the console log
and then
we print the function
and then we call the function
okay so now we got the function printed
but
it's not in a stringified form
so i could
just
add an empty string to it and it will
stringify the function for us
so now we are pretty close but what
we're missing is
the call to the function
so let's see if we can add that
okay so let's check
there's a semicolon
i'm just double checking
yeah
i think we got it
so this is one way of doing it i i don't
really like this call immediately after
so i'm going to change that to
an immediately invoked function
so now we're calling
we're declaring the function in
parenthesis
and then we call the output of those
parentheses with these two parentheses
so now we can see that now we're missing
the parenthesis that is in front
so that is a little bit nicer to me
let's see if we can do this with a
template literal instead to clean it up
more
so here we do f
and then
the parenthesis
after
and the parenthesis before
so there we have it that looks pretty
good
and i think it's quite understandable as
well
okay let's take this coin and see how
small we can make it converting the
function to an arrow function and so on
so we'll do f
equals
underscore arrow
f equals underscore
so we have the start
and now we can probably remove
okay let's check if it's still valid now
so if
equals
underscore
so f is the variable and then this is
the input to the
arrow function
and then we return immediately
console.log
and here we create the entire program
so everything looks correct
back take
parenthesis
yeah so this is my favorite one actually
because this one is neat and small
it's not as readable as the other one i
would say but
this is the nicest one so people have
actually gone super crazy with these
coins
there's something called the circle of
coins
where instead of just printing your own
source code
you output code
that is executable in another
programming language
and that code
will output code that is
executable in the next programming
language and you keep doing that going
from language to language until you
eventually
output the original code that you
started with
so you go through all of these languages
just to come back to the original source
code that you started running so you
could start anywhere on the circle
and if you have all the programming
languages installed you could execute
program after program after program
until you arrive at the same starting
point so that's just absolutely crazy
and it's only the joy of programming
that creates these things
so it's it's very cool
there's this talk
called the art of code that i will link
in the description that's where i first
heard about coins and i really recommend
you watch it
also in the talk he has created his own
language based on rock lyrics and in the
end
he writes fistbus the fizzbuzz example
in his programming language and then he
actually plays a song because the
programming language is lyrics
the output or the fistbust program is
actually just looks like a rock ballad
song
so he plays that song in the end and i
really recommend you watch that so
hopefully you got inspired maybe you
learned something i'd really appreciate
if you liked the video if you subscribe
to the channel and if you share it with
a friend
so thank you so much for watching and
i'll see you in the next video
[Music]
you